Todo a partir de la configuración simple que describí.
Mi esposa ha hecho pruebas de campo
con algunos de estos microscopios
lavando mi ropa cuando los olvido
en la secadora.
Así que resulta que son a prueba de agua y...
(Risas)
aquí hay agua fluorescente,
y no sé si en realidad se puede ver esto.
Esto también muestra cómo funciona el alcance de la proyección.
Pueden ver el rayo, cómo se proyecta y se curva.
¿Podemos encender las luces de nuevo?
Rápidamente les mostraré,
porque me estoy quedando sin tiempo,
lo que nos cuesta fabricarlo.
La idea principal era la fabricación de rollo a rollo,
así construimos este a 50 centavos de partes y costos.
(Aplausos)
Y esto nos permite
pensar en un nuevo paradigma en microscopía,
que llamamos microscopía de usar y tirar.
Les daré un panorama general
de algunas de las partes involucradas.
Esta es una hoja de papel.
Aquí estábamos pensando la idea.
Esta es una hoja de papel A4.
Estas son las 3 etapas que ven.
Y los componentes ópticos, si miran el recuadro arriba a la derecha,
teníamos que encontrar una manera de fabricar lentes
en papel para muy altas producciones,
por eso usa un proceso de autoensamblado
y tensión superficial
para construir lentes acromáticas en el propio papel.
Ahí van las lentes.
Hay algunas fuentes de luz.
Y, esencialmente, a la postre,
todas las piezas se alinean gracias al origami,
gracias a que el origami nos permite
una precisión a escala micrométrica de la alineación óptica.
A pesar de parecer un juguete sencillo,
los aspectos de ingeniería que contiene
algo como esto son bastante sofisticados.
Aquí vemos otra cosa obvia que hicimos
típicamente para demostrar
que estos microscopios son robustos,
fuimos al tercer piso y lo dejamos caer al suelo.
Ahí está, y sobrevive.
Para nosotros, el siguiente paso en realidad
es terminar las pruebas de campo.
Estamos empezando a finales del verano.
Estamos en una etapa en la que haremos miles de microscopios.
Esa sería la primera vez que estaríamos
haciendo pruebas de campo con la mayor densidad
de microscopios en un lugar dado.
Hemos empezado la recolección de datos para la malaria,
la enfermedad de Chagas y la giardia de los propios pacientes.
Y quiero dejarles esta imagen.
Yo no lo había previsto,
pero es un vínculo muy interesante
entre la educación práctica en ciencias
y la salud mundial.
¿Cuáles son las herramientas que les estamos dando
a los niños que van a combatir
esta sopa monstruosa mañana?
Me encantaría que ellos pudieran imprimir
un pliegoscopio y llevárselo en sus bolsillos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)